hello and thank you for joining us today
welcome to the advancing science of
spatial biology conference
my name is sarah warren i'm a senior
director of translational science at
nanostring technologies
and i'm thrilled to introduce and share
today's agenda with you as well as a few
announcements
today the conference will start with a
plenary session featuring dr peter
sorger
and then we'll have three scientific
tracks one on covet 19 research
one on spatial genomics and one on
spatial genomics data analysis
the coven 19 research track will feature
presentations by dr david ting from
massachusetts general hospital
dr robert schwartz and dr alan borzak
from wild cornell medicine
dr ussa stegelstor from the broad
institute and dr gordon zhang from beth
israel deaconess medical center this
will be followed by a roundtable
discussion with all of the speakers
the spatial genomics track will be
moderated by kit furman a product
manager at nanostring who focuses on
geomics rna
assays and it will feature presentations
by dr sergeant
sergio and dr laura perrin from
children's hospital in los
angeles dr karen pelko from the broad
institute
and dr muha yang from the national ming
yang university
and in the final track spatial genomics
data analysis
which will be hosted by jason reeves a
senior scientist in translational
science
we will have presentations by dr chris
mason from weill cornell medical school
dr christina curtis from stanford
university dr omar by rachteger
and dr alexandra avivadis from the
welcome sanger institute
and dr ionis blackos from beth israel
deaconess medical suspender
and this session will also be followed
by a roundtable discussion
before we get started i have a few
announcements to share
first please participate in our
nanostring gamification event
and earn points to be eligible to win a
pair of apple airpod pros
as well as other prizes by participating
in a wide range of activities
earn points by attending session
presentations joining a live geomegs
interactive data experience
engaging in the virtual lab exploring
the exhibit hall
interacting with booth reps downloading
posters and participating in the social
media
good luck second we have just announced
the whole transcriptomatless is now
available through the technology access
program
and we have released the eight locations
of the geomex premier access program
sites that will offer geomix cancer
transcriptome atlas service you can find
more information about both of these
programs on the nanostring website
finally we have several founding members
of the new geomex covid19 consortium
under the geomics translational
leadership network speaking today
we look forward to hearing their latest
research results and
even more look forward to their future
work that will feature meta-analyses of
all of these covent samples
without further ado it gives me great
pleasure to introduce
today's plenary speaker dr peter sorger
dr sorger is the otto crier professor of
systems biology at harvard medical
school
and has worked extensively on developing
techniques for multi-omic analyses of
cancer
dr sorga will be speaking today about
the role of spatial profiling in cancer
and infectious disease
on behalf of nanostring we're proud to
bring you this online event
we hope that you will find the advancing
science of spatial biology conference
both valuable and enjoyable
thank you
thank you very much for that kind
introduction
i'm very pleased uh to get to this
conference
for you a little bit about the things
that we've been doing recently
on uh the spatial analysis of immune
micro environments and as you heard from
the introduction
uh that's going to go come from both the
the work that we've historically been
been doing in a variety of cancers and
i'll show you
a few of them but particularly melanoma
and then some more recent research in
which we've been applying similar
technologies to look at
the immune environments in
cobit 19 as you'll see both in resolving
infections
and also in lethal infections so let me
just start by
uh telling you that i have a
relationship with a few of the companies
that i'm going to talk about today
most relevant is uh is nanostring on
who's
sab that i serve and i do want to point
out particularly as regards the covet 19
research sitting
this um what i'm going to show you today
includes preliminary unpublished data
that have been submitted but not yet
subjected
to peer review so in the last few years
a lot of
interest has developed in uh what are
called tissue atlases or tissue and
tumor atlases
and the goal behind these atlases is to
begin to bring
to spatially resolved views of human
biology
what large-scale genomic efforts like
the cancer genome atlas
were able to do with cancer genomics and
specifically that is
to build an online browsable resource in
which
you can begin to look at the
interactions between cells shown here
in this sort of h-tan or the national
cancer
institute's human tumor atlas network
above and sort of contrasting with tcga
below
to look at cell types and interactions
uh the ways in which
cells signal to each other how they
formed uh
pattern tissues and then how those uh
patterns actually form the physiological
functions
that we see in normal conditions and
eventually become
uh transformed and so the expectation is
that these
sorts of atlases will go online over the
next couple of years
over a variety of diseases particularly
in oncology and that will then provide
us access to the type of spatial
information
that i'm going to show you today and
that you're going to hear about from
other speakers
our own particular interest in this
focuses on the earliest stages of
melanoma
melanoma as uh most of you know is a
uh a serious disease when it becomes
metastatic
but can be completely cured if it's
still localized
and can be resected and so a critical
question in the treatment of melanoma
is to work out what are the dangerous
lesions and what are the benign ones
and to do that we want to understand a
lot of the molecular drivers
uh much better and that includes the
micro environment
initially the early genetic events and
epigenetic events that lead to
the transformation of melanocytes
into these aggressive forms
the role that immune surveillance
naturally placed
so this is one of the diseases in which
immunotherapies have been most effective
and immune surveillance is critical in
the natural setting for
the immune system to be able to edit
away a damaged skin that often has
arisen
as a consequence of uv exposure and the
accumulation of oncogenic mutations
and then as you can see with regard to
the treatment issue that i brought up a
moment ago that
the relatively subtle differences in
many cases between benign lesions in
which
oncogenic mutations lead to senescence
and these small invasive legions that
will then eventually go on
typically fairly early in their
development to malignancy
and that represents the primary
challenge with respect to treatment
i'm going to tell you also about data
and this will be much of my talk today
that has come
much more recently from the construction
of a
tissue atlas for covid19 in this case
what we're trying to understand is the
natural course of disease
and we're going to contrast what happens
in non-humane primate models which are
widely used both to understand disease
mechanism but also to develop
vaccines um and which naturally resolves
and the infection resolves in these
animals and we're going to contrast to
that to what happens in humans
um in which for the cases talk we're
going to be looking at decedents who've
died as a consequence
of the disease and we want to find out
what are the natural course of those two
different types of infection
what are the idiosyncratic features in
humans because
almost all of them have serious
comorbidities and these are thought to
be an important part
in the development of serious cobit 19
and and its sequelae and then finally
what sorts of drugs might be repurposed
to mitigate symptoms
and also incidentally how might we use
animal models better to understand
vaccination procedures although that's
not something
i'll address today and these two are
linked
in many ways by the need to better
understand immune micro
environments so here's a fairly general
sort of overview of long micro
environment and
if you work your way through it you'll
see not only are there many cell types
that interact particularly between the
immune system
and both endothelial and epithelial
lineages but of course there's both
uh the direct cell cell contact but also
the production of a whole series of
cytokines
um many of which are listed here and
these will both be
signals to other cells and also part of
the response network so you have this
sort of someostatic mechanism
by which in the case of oncology the
natural immune surveillance plays out
and cells tumor cells try to co-opt that
both
escape from the immune system and then
in many cases actually get a growth
advantage
in the case of covid19 increasingly it
looks as though
there's excessive activation of these
pathways in human patients and that's
what leads
to serious disease now the technologies
we've been using from this
uh have really been developed only
within the last couple of years
and in the research that i'm going to
show you we're almost always guided
initially
by pathology and so we get specimens
from human patients
those are almost always subjected to
examination
of chemically stained samples so-called
h e staining
and that gives rise to the primary
diagnosis and
and our goal in most cases is to get at
the underlying molecular events
between let's say an aggressive tumor
and a benign tumor
or in the case of cova between serious
and resolving disease
and the methods that i'm going to show
you today are first
involving multiplex immunofluorescence
so in which we can do
subcellular resolution um
multi-channel up to in some cases 60
channel immunofluorescence across whole
slides so that allows us
to get cell type states and um
and markers across a large region of
tissue
we then do spatially resolved rna
sequencing and you'll see that
that involves a few technologies but
i'll show you work that comes from the
nano string
geomets dsp platform and then very
recently we've developed ways of taking
histopathological specimens and
examining them in the mass spectrometer
now one of the critical features of the
diseases that we're looking at
is the production of fixed tissue and
their examination by h
e here that classic uh staining modality
is almost always a diagnostic
necessity and so we really have little
or no access
to frozen specimens in early melanoma
instead we have to work with those
specimens that make up the vast majority
of
all specimens and clinical workflows and
that are these formaldehyde fixed and
paraffin embedded
sections and in in the case of imaging
that actually makes for much higher
quality but in the case
of the methods shown below either mass
spectrometry rna-seq that represents
a very substantial challenge so i think
there are many methods for spatially
resolved
rna sequencing being developed for
frozen specimens but really the
variety of those that work in the fixed
spacemen case is relatively more limited
and then ultimately of course we want to
pull these data together into some kind
of
integrated data analysis in which we're
able to look at features in molecular
space
and in morphological space let me just
show you a couple of examples of that
uh here's an uh one of these highly
multiplexed images
um this is actually a 24 plex image but
i'm just showing you four of those
channels to make it a little easier to
see what's going on
you can see the scale here about 400
microns across
at much lower resolution the pathology
tells us that this is
a region of abnormality when we then
look in high resolution we can see that
the melanocytes which make the pigment
in the skin
are here invading downwards into the
dermis and so that's the beginning of a
potentially
dangerous melanoma there's been both
hyper proliferation
and movement out of the normal plane we
can see
various immune cells stained with cd20
or cd3 here and then the cytokeratin the
blue marker helps to tell us
where we see the normal dermis and
epidermis and then this can then be
turned into as i alluded to before these
high dimensional features for further
analysis
one of the really interesting aspects of
these
types of specimens and this will come up
again when we look at the covid
19 is that is that within a symbol
sample you can end up with dramatically
different regions over
length scales of hundreds of microns so
in particular in this case
we're looking at a melanoma in situ so
this is an earliest stage of an invasive
melanoma we've actually seen
hyperproliferation here of the
melanocytes
just below the skin so the blue pan
cytokeratin
off to the left of that is a region in
which the immune system is successfully
engaging
and killing those tumor cells so this
would be
the immune response that we would hope
to have and that we might stimulate with
immune checkpoint therapy
and then to the extreme left is what we
interpret
as a region where all the melanocytes
have actually been successfully resolved
by this
immune regression and over many such
samples the hope is that we can
view this as as a bit of a time series
um
in which we're seeing different aspects
of the competition between the tumor
and the immune system and then
particularly in the case of these
imaging technologies that i'm showing
you here's something that's blown up now
about 25 times down below we're looking
at a single cell at the bottom
and these are single t-cells engaging
single
immune cells we've been able to select
them out of a 3d data set
and you can actually see the formation
of contacts between them
and then for the exhaustion markers here
the t cell markers lag 3 and tim 3
on the right hand panel you can see that
they've been actually sorted away from
the
immune synapse that's formed between the
t cell and the immune cell
so in addition to sort of the
intensities and the enumeration of
things
there's a lot of this morphological
information that until a year or two ago
we thought was going to be available to
us in cultured cells but now these
pictures are essentially as good as what
we would also see in a tissue culture so
those questions that we had previously
addressed in culture
are now addressable uh in these sorts of
specimens from human patients
so the second approach that we've taken
to this is to
begin to take morphologically defined
regions um
both from the classical histopathology
but also from high dimensional imaging
and now try to find the transcriptional
programs that are associated with that
here you see an example that we got we
got help with from the company via
the early access program we've defined
different regions
in the tumor in this case you can see
those drawn in the upper left
and then we've gone through and actually
made multiple regional
pics from each of those and then on the
right you can sort of see the resulting
sort of data and the way in which it can
be clustered and one of the things you
learned very quickly from doing these
kind of
uh spatially resolved
comparisons is that the types of
programs that have typically been
defined for melanoma so the two famous
ones are a tumor suppressor program and
the so-called mitf
program that those actually don't
co-exist in a specimen like this
they're actually spatially localized for
each other and then down below you're
seeing
in the green up above this tumor
suppressor program down below you're
seeing the mitf program
recognized by gene set enrichment
analysis and then uh
mapped back on to the various regions in
which we had done
uh the spatially resolved profiling and
so
you actually see that there's a natural
evolution here and of course we're most
interested in the types of differences
that distinguish
the areas of ongoing tumor growth and
invasion from those
in which immune regression has been most
active
and then the final method and the one
that's most recently developed in the
lab is to begin to bring discovery
proteomics to bear
so this seemed fairly ambitious but
we've actually found that we can do with
proteomics more
than we can do with conventional uh bulk
rna-seq
and we can actually look quite deeply
and you're going to see quite a lot of
this type of discovery proteomics
uh in the next part of the talk where i
talk about the covet 19 atlas
the basic concept again is to start with
a histological specimen we'll typically
image that as i've shown you a moment
ago
using multiplex imaging i will then take
the next section down dewax scrape it
and the type of proteomics we do is tmt
labeled multiplex proteomics so that
allows us to look at 16 specimens in
parallel
in a single shot in the mass
spectrometer and to compare
the abundance of peptides from one to
the other with no missing values
so that really provides the capacity to
do deep profiling
but also to look at infection or time
series
in the case of the samples i'm going to
show you we've actually done
phosphopeptide enrichment as well so we
can pull out phosphopeptides and look at
them separately
and then we eventually run them on a
what's called an ms3 mass spectrometer
which allows us to precisely quantify
these isobaric
tags and you're going to see quite a bit
of that type of data as i mentioned a
moment ago
so in the covid 19 tissue atlas that's
really engaged us
taking these technologies developed
initially for oncology immunoprofiling
and now
applying them to looking at covid19
we've managed to look at two sets of
specimens the first is
acute viral infection in rhesus macaques
and these are healthy animals a couple
of usually about six to twelve years old
they will naturally resolve the
infection over seven to fourteen days
and they've been tested with
re-challenge experiments where they're
then
re-sampled by with nasal swabs for
example to show that
once they've seen a single round of
infection they're then resistant
to disease and of course that's the type
of resistance that now is being tested
in vaccination programs in the case of
the specimens that i'm showing you we
actually
have tracheal and lung parenchyma that
have been biopsied
um after necropsy and so we have some
ability to look at the tissues
and we see this as a model for a natural
immunity and the way in which a disease
would progress
and then we contrast that with human
decedents
in this case we have similar specimens
acquired at autopsy
i'm going to show you today only the
first cohort which consists of three
decedents and we have to recall that
they have very diverse comorbidities
including diabetes lupus in one case
but we have 30 additional samples that
are in mid process
and the specific atlas that we're
planning to release
um we think uh early this fall will
consist of
these two cohorts so the type of
analysis i'm showing you
today in preliminary form we'll have uh
additional backing
and just to recall uh what we're trying
to catch in the case of the non-human
primate the nhp as i'll call them those
are the rhesus macaques we'd like to
look uh pre-infection
ultimately but not in today's talk we
look with vaccination
we'd like to see them at the peak of
viral response and as the time in which
they resolve
and that turns out to be about 14 days
and then they're also these
re-challenged specimens
in contrast the human um decedents will
have
entered the hospital and proceeded
in many cases fairly rapidly through
disease in some cases in as little as 48
hours
in other cases over the course of
several
weeks at which point those who passed
away and
volunteered to have
have their tissues examined would then
be subjected to the analysis that i'm
going to show you so we have these two
different diseases
also separated by two different species
so one of the biggest surprises for us
when we did this it's only two months
ago now
was that actually we can get around 7000
proteins quantified
uh on an nhp specimen or a human
specimen about
the same and that would contrast for
these types of profiling techniques deep
shotgun proteomics of around 10 to 11
000 proteins on the best
possible frozen specimen so this is
actually a surprisingly
deep look at what is after all a very
small
specimen only five microns thick and
that can be
uh fixed and therefore preserved in the
case of the oncology studies that's
hopeful be
helpful excuse me because we can go back
in time in the case of
the covid studies it'll also allows us
to inactivate virus which means that
all of these studies can be done under
low biocontainment
so what actually do you see under these
circumstances so
let me show you what i'm going to call
single sample
gene set enrichment but it's not
actually genes it's proteins so we
use all of the tools that have been
developed for rna
transcript analysis but here we apply
them to proteins and not surprisingly we
see extremely strong
interferon alpha and gamma responses so
that's the classical viral
response what's nice isn't exactly the
same specimen only five microns away
we can then do the high resolution
imaging that i
showed you a little bit about earlier
and we can do this in all sorts of
different channels and we can go in and
ask okay are
which cells in fact are interferon
activated the answer is it's both immune
epithelial and endothelial cells what
are the
different types of cells that are
recruited and we can enumerate
macrophages t
cells b cells etc
we find under these circumstances uh
that for
proteins like mx1 which is an interferon
induced
antiviral protein that across the
specimens we have there's a surprisingly
good correlation between
the levels that we measure by mass
spectrometry
and the levels we bother by imaging on
on match
specimens so that gives one some
confidence that these two very different
modalities
are returning results that can be
integrated
with each other as i mentioned briefly
earlier actually it's also possible to
look at phosphorylation which seems to
us
particularly surprising we're not
currently doing that
in the autopsy specimens because of the
uneven period
between death and the beginning of
fixation but in the case of these
nhp specimens that was very well
controlled and so we can now see these
time courses
the samples are going from control at
the bottom and pink
up to the re-challenge at the top so
imagine a resolved infection
and for ifit three a classic interferon
response factor you can see that it
becomes quite strongly phosphorylated
at day two which is also the peak of the
interferon response
and so this and i'll come back to how
these pieces fit together again
but this allows us to look at the signal
transduction events
um that take place in these specimens
now one of the surprising things when we
took this initial set of samples and
we've done it a few times and seen
the same basic result was we saw a
fundamental difference between
uninfected specimens and infected
specimens from
the right to the left but within any
given
time point and even within a single lung
we saw a big difference you can see 2 a
and b
on the top and 2 c and d on the bottom
and we were really
sort of concerned about that why why was
there a difference between
uh the specimen uh in in these analyses
which seemed otherwise to be quite
reproducible
and the answer of course lay in these
region to region
differences that you see so here's a
single
lung specimen from from one of the
non-human primates and within one of
those lungs this will be taken at day
two
and we're looking at here a macrophage
marker in red in the background this is
very
low magnification so you're looking at
almost three centimeters of tissue
uh here across at this scale what we see
is there are regions that are relatively
normal
r4 at the top we see regions that are
positive
for virus and we can just detect that
directly based on spike and capsid
protein staining
they've recruited a few macrophages but
then finally the regions r3 is an
example that are called consolidated and
those can
be seen even when you do cat scanning
and those are the regions of the lung in
which the alveoli have
filled up either with fluid or with
other
immune cell types and you've lost the
respiratory function
and these regions are actually
remarkably different from each other
even though they've been recovered from
a single animal
and you can see now on the right the
uninfected we see this picovirus in day
two those are the orange and black dots
with a lot of difference from one
specimen to the next
and then that goes way down by day four
the animals are already successfully
clearing
the virus positive virus positivity
presumably through this interferon type
response and so we can then take what
would otherwise be sort of
a confounder in the analysis and turn it
into a critical variable so we can look
directly at the relationship
even in a single specimen between virus
load
and the load of macrophages and other
consolidants
relative to the biology and i think
that's a simple example
of the value of getting these spatially
resolved pictures because
uh in almost all of the things that we
would look at
either in this infectious disease or in
cancer really the region to region
differences are nearly as great as they
are
from one patient to the next
and here's just one other view where
i've shown some additional markers and
you can see how
different that is the consolidated
region if you look in the upper panel
there you can see a whole bunch of
what we call reactive or activated
inflammatory macrophages cd16 positive
and you can see those are absent from
that relatively normal region
the consolidated region at r3 remember
is virus negative and the presumption is
those cells have already cleared the
virus and that it was an earlier stage
of the infection
so there are many similarities between
animals and human responses i've just
pulled out a couple of these again
interferon genes should in this context
be seen as interferon induced proteins
um you can see that big peak at day two
in the high virus sample
from the non-human primates that's the
red stripe going across the
upper cluster diagram and you can see
something approximately similar in
humans where
there seems to be a lot more interferon
induction in patient
[Music]
one and two than there is in patient
three and we'll return to that in a
moment
and if you look at some of these
pathways as a sort of classic reactant
pathway and analysis
you can see that interferon signaling is
up we're seeing a lot of remodeling
of the extracellular matrix there are
other chemokines and cytokines that are
activated
and these are sort of features of the
disease that have also been observed in
the blood and are things that we
expected to see but one of the
biggest surprises from this preliminary
analysis was that even if interferon
responses alpha and gamma here are
strong in humans
if we now look at viral burden and
compare that to inflammation
you'll see that they are uncorrelated or
even in this small
cohort they're actually anti-correlated
so that's very different than what's
seen in animals and in animals is what
we would actually expect for infectious
diseases of that type the greater the
viral burden the greater the induction
of the interferon response
here we see something quite different
which is the greater the viral burden
potentially the less the inflammatory
response
but it's fundamentally uncoordinated and
that from work from 10 over and others
is becoming
clear as a characteristic of covid19 and
terminal patients and humans that is to
say that
the virus and the response to the virus
become
incorrectly coordinated and you no
longer see that natural
course of evolution and that's the
one of the single largest differences we
see between humans and these naturally
resolving animal infections
let me show you two other differences um
the first is these cytokine storms
what's observed in
humans is there are many cytokines that
are upregulated
here i show you a few of them and it's
an interesting feature
of the mass spectrometry that it can
directly measure the levels of soluble
cytokines in the microenvironment
in situ and that this includes uh
classic chemokines and cytokines like
il1 beta for example
as well as a whole series of
interleukins and some are up and some
are down and
they vary from one protein to the next
but decedent number two in our
experiments had a particularly acute
cytokine and sporm involving a wide
variety
of these factors and i've just pulled a
couple of them out below you can see in
the case of
il-1 beta for example this enormous
induction in patient two
um perhaps 10 to 10 to 50 fold
and that's also a sodium with up
regulation of its
one of the components of its receptor
il1
wrap the other thing we can
detect in humans but we see relatively
little and i'll get back to this in a
moment
in uh in in animals is the
end stage of clotting so one of the most
serious complications of covid infection
in humans is
thrombosis and the formation of these
inappropriate clots
which which are thought in some cases to
be the cause of death
and so a factor 13a at the end
takes different residues in fibrin
they're multiple crosslinks
but the one that we find most abundantly
in the mass spectrometer is shown here
between a glutamate and a lysine at
416 and 237 and you can see we can
actually detect very significant
increases both in fibrin itself so in
the protein that actually makes up the
clot
end in the formation of the crosslink so
that's a very nice
end stage of biochemical end stage that
you're seeing in a tissue specimen
because you know that's really
the biology that's driving these
thrombotic processes
so very clear in humans thought to be
relevant we can detect many steps
what do we see in in non-human primates
and this
came as a substantial surprise to us and
that was that the
the actual level of platelet complement
and fibrin activation so those are
different aspects of that
uh thrombotic response if anything
they're actually down regulated
in the non-human primates and you can
see that as we go from sort of the red
stripe and the controls
remember when you scale these things you
see normal here potentially as red
they actually dip down into the blue so
they're down regulated
significantly over dozens of genes and
then they
return when these animals have largely
resolved the infection
and so to understand that actually we
turn once again to the spatial
transcript profiling
and we thought we would compare the
regions i showed you before so what
happens if we look in an area within a
single lung of an infected animal
between virus positive and consolidated
regions
and we compare that to a no virus region
and an uninfected control
and in this case now what we see is the
activation of the platelets fibrinogen
lectins etc so
the difference between humans and
the uh rhesus macaques is
in humans we have delocalized thrombotic
activation we have
clots all the way through the lungs that
eventually propagates into the blood and
becomes
uh life-threatening in the animals in
contrast
this is a highly localized reaction and
as best we can tell it's followed by the
activation
of the enzymes involved in the
dissolution of clots and so you see this
homeostatic regulation and in fact
clotting is a normal part of the
response
to serious viral infection that should
be localized
and then should be shut down so the
striking thing in the human patients is
that
normally homeostatic mechanism has
broken down
and that really explains the difference
we think
between these two different types of
infections
so one of the more interesting aspects
we feel of this type of
multi-um omic analysis involving imaging
transcription and proteomics is you can
now begin to look at many
steps in a cascade not just as gene sets
which i've shown you a little bit as
but also as biological pathways
so in the particular case of cobit 19
we're able to see inflammasome
activation i didn't show you that in
immune cells that would be expected to
lead to production of il1
beta and we can actually detect that
directly
by mass spectrometry we can see the
receptors going up we can see nf kappa b
going up in some cases for some of these
pathways we can see
transcription factors becoming
phosphorylated and then we can see the
sequelae both in terms of
response genes and here's a little
enrichment plot by gene said in richmond
or alternatively in terms of cellular
phenotypes or things like fibrinogen
activation
that i showed you a moment ago now
what's sort of the
sort of the current state of this
analysis and i think
one of the things we've we've come to
see is the immune landscape is really
extremely complicated so here are the
m1-like macrophages as a gene set in
richmond again remember that's protein
space
extremely strongly enriched so that
would be taken as evidence of the
activation
of inflammatory macrophages you can see
down
below in which the different days day
two
and then day two with high virus day
four d14 etc
we're actually seeing macrophage
activation particularly
in the high virus case and then the
right is a sort of medium resolution
view in which
we're seeing a series of immune markers
that would be
uh would allow us to look at t cells b
cells
and some types of macrophages and you
can see in these lungs this
extraordinary recruitment
of different immune cell types leading
eventually to consolidation and
in many cases we don't actually fully
understand
the macrophage types here we don't
understand the marker combinations
that they involve and that's an area of
both now joint molecular
and image based analysis in humans even
more strikingly once again there's the
activation of these macrophages but when
we go from one patient to the next
we actually see dramatic differences
even if macrophages
are present in those patients they
actually have different phenotypes
so just if you look at the left hand
column at the very lowest resolution
you're seeing different resolutions to
the right you can see
h1 at the top row there is red h2 is
green and down below
there is much less of anything and that
represents
two different polarization states of
macrophages in h1n and h2 and then
h3 which remember that's the decedent
with the highest viral load remarkably
enough
has a very impaired macrophage-based
immune response it was also the patient
with a remarkably poor interferon
response
and that was a patient i should say that
actually also had substantial thrombosis
so we can now begin to see the sort of
decoupling of these things that would be
normally part of of the response to a
virus like this
so let me just conclude by saying a
little bit about
what we've started to discover in the
inflammatory and thrombotic features of
covid
i should say cobit 19. excuse me so on
the left
are sort of those micro-environment
features between the blood
the lung parenchyma and different
alveolar cell types and we're able to
look at some of those pathways we've
looked at a lot of gene set enrichment
analysis over the last 20 minutes or so
but in some cases we can trace complete
mechanisms
and on the right we're seeing this
aspect that seems
particularly strong in sars infection
and that's really the thrombotic
component in which you get deposition of
plaques
and i think the evidence we have has
suggests that in animals this occurs as
we would expect it in a localized and
resolving fashion
but in humans with their comorbidities
it becomes runaway
and so better understanding of these
immune environments i think is going to
clearly require
this kind of localized analysis as well
as much better understanding of
individual
cell types involved and that's sort of
where things stand for
the purpose of this and we will be
releasing um the data that i'm showing
you today in the next
month or two because we think this is
the kind of thing that's effectively
distributed to the community
for joint analysis so the last
note to say is there's a lot of work
still to be done here
in making atlas data shareable so the
type of images that i showed you today
are currently shared almost entirely by
people sitting around a microscope this
is actually a contemporary picture on
the left
and uh and and
it's actually a hands-on experience
where you're sort of led through
and the analogy we're using is like a
dos sent shown on the right where a
docent takes you through a museum
and we've actually built a series of
software platforms i don't have time to
show you today but actually allow you to
be led
through a through the atlas data that
i've shown you today in a kind of guided
manner
and that's known as project minerva and
here are some resources you can find i
think you can search for it on our
github
so thank you very much for your
attention um it's really been a pleasure
talking to you today and i'd like to
thank the people who did this work
all of our high dimensional spatially
resolved imaging is done
as a collaboration with sandro santagata
who's a practicing pathologist
we have multiple pathologists helping
with us and i should also call out dan
baruch and amanda martino who's
are responsible for giving us the the
non-human primate specimens and robert
perdera and his colleagues
for the human decedents now expanding to
30. and we've
got a group of software engineers
clinicians and postdoctoral fellows who
contributed to this
and all of whom are continuing to try to
get the steady
data ready for release and then just
thank you for the
this in which we're embedded uh which is
20 different research groups from all
across
massachusetts all working on developing
diagnostics and
modern approaches to therapeutic
discovery thank you very much
thank you so much dr sarger it was a
wonderful presentation
if you'd be so kind we have just a few
questions for you uh and the first one
is what are
some of the challenges and opportunities
in using the spatially resolved data in
analysis of tissue specimens
and what is current state of the art
so i think these are all um newly
developed methods
um so uh the and and as i alluded to in
my talk there is a difference between
what can be done with a frozen specimen
particularly in genomics where
dissociative rna sequencing is very
powerful
and what is possible with these clinical
types of specimens where you have
fixed material and therefore it's a
relatively greater challenge
so i think we have we have really uh
sort of two sets of challenges and let
me give you a quick opportunity the
first set of challenges just be
familiarizing ourselves with with new
methods
um and you can see even from my talk
today with the
proteomics that we can use gene said
enrichment analysis et cetera so fairly
familiar tools even as we do spatially
resolved omic analysis
i think the imaging represents a much
more substantial challenge because
pathologists are extremely good at
looking at these tissue images
and developing a diagnosis that's in
fact how they diagnose most disease
but most of us don't really know how to
talk about that we don't have the
equivalent of an enriched gene we don't
know how to talk about these
three-dimensional
organizations and so i think that
represents a sort of conceptual
challenge
and then the second one which again i
touched on the end is the software for
doing this
is actually way behind the measurement
technology so actually
you know you know enumerating all of
these cell types and tissue and being
accurate and
sharing it none of that is really being
developed i think it's over the next
couple of years
that we'll see that come through the
opportunity is
is is really both with respect to
connecting this to diagnosis so
histopathology has been around since the
1890s in its current form
practitioners have gotten better but the
microscope is not all that different
than it used to be and the stains are so
i think if we can connect modern
technology to that
we're going to see an enormous capacity
to get molecular mechanisms associated
with
classic pathological diagnosis and with
respect to sort of a research agenda
i think we can see many cases where if
you mush everything together it's
actually
quite confounding and we know that to be
true in bulk seek versus
single cell c but now when we can
spatially resolve sections
we can say boy this looks like there's a
measurement problem but now we resolve
it and we say oh no these are two
completely different regions
and in fact we can we can develop a much
more precise
spatially resolved explanation of the
phenotype so i think
those are really the opportunities and
this will be an entirely new type of
data
um it'll look just like the early days
of sequencing data
with this strong spatial dimension so i
think it's very exciting
i agree with that for sure uh and
obviously you know the
the work that we're doing with covet is
is brand new and we're inventing new
fields but there's a large body of
evidence that we can draw on already
from the research been done in oncology
so
do you think that the immune
environments that have been established
in the tumor
are similar to what's going on in the
infectious disease or
are the results that you've seen purely
related to the methodologies that you've
used to profile each
yeah so it's a great question you know i
in in a talk like this you know i'm no
infectious disease expert we're
largely in oncology and so we we tend to
link these things
together by the method that we use such
as the opportunity and the challenge
presented by the current pandemic
but actually i think we've become much
more interested in the
in the question as you cast it is what
actually is the difference between
the response say to an acute and a
chronic infection they're different from
each other
um as compared to to what we see in in a
cancer and i can say that
from the current profiling that's coming
up there there are surprising
similarities and differences which is to
say that there are
cell types particularly in the case that
we've looked at in macrophages
that are predominant in the end-stage
cova diseases that we actually
don't see in the acute disease and we we
also don't see in oncology so they're
marker combinations and transcriptional
states that that are probably very very
rare in those other circumstances so i
think actually integrating that
will be interesting and then there are
diseases
like tuberculosis where in the lung you
actually have
these long-term uh sort of individually
evolving
foci that look a bit like a tumor so
they're actually quite different from
each other both with respect to their
microenvironment and their genetics so i
think that's really the the comparison
we'd like to do and i think many people
are becoming very interested in that
yeah i agree there's certainly a lot of
complexity in the immune response and a
lot of
data that's generated as a result of
these multi
profiling mechanisms so can you speak a
little bit about the challenges in
sharing the data and
and making it available and useful for
the community
so i you know i think for many of us
involved in this we're this is an area
of considerable concern
i think that this is you know transcript
data in principle it's
depositable in you know geo in the same
repositories that we have but
that those repositories don't have any
concept of
of space so if we were to deposit you
know 30
gsp data sets or picks or individual
specimens that had a particular
geometry we don't know how we would
deposit that the imaging data
that we have has no repository in the
united states
europeans actually have been well ahead
in developing repositories for some of
these types of data
but we're in the i think worrying and
somewhat peculiar position of having
huge amounts of data coming along all of
which is intended
tended by congress to be shareable
aggressively shareable
for which we have none of the
infrastructure for sharing
um and so i think that's an area that's
going to need a lot of attention
and um and and we don't want to repeat
some of what happened with the big
genomic data sets
which is analysis came way after data
collection
and so we're hoping to get you know the
companies with deep expertise in this
google amazon these companies to
actually engage
in as part of their effort i think
particularly in cobit 19 and helping
make the resources available to get this
data into the hands of people who can
interpret it
i i agree and i think copenhagen
certainly presents a unique opportunity
for us to create these
these shared resources that we need can
you speak a bit about your plans for
creating and releasing the covet 19 data
atlas that you described
yeah so our commitment and that has been
to release it pre-publication
so as soon as the data is sort of
basically analyzed we'll get it out
there and it will
go into three separate locations sadly
one of them is of course the proteomics
data will go into pride where people
hopefully can find it we'll try to build
a website that gives you the index
the spatial transcript profiling will go
into
into the geotype data set but we're
going to have to work out just on an ad
hoc basis how we combine the spatial
information and at the moment there's no
good way
to share the image data outside of this
kind of technology that i briefly
alluded to this sort of
ghost scent based thing minerva but that
that'll actually come out as movies so
um so i think it's it's we're committed
to releasing it it's really the absence
and i think many other
people working in this space it's it's
it's really the need for the
infrastructure
and the standards um is going to have to
have to be developed in real time
wow i agree well thank you so much dr
sterner for
taking time to speak with us today for
sharing with us your exciting
pre-publication data we're looking very
much forward to seeing the publications
come out and seeing how the work
advances
well you should be able to find them on
med archive or bioarchive
as soon as we finished writing and thank
you very much
thank you very much for your time for
inviting me to this exciting event and
for your questions